hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast disruptive technologies for
improving disease resistance in crop
plants so many genomes and so little
time I am Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Doug kale
genomics Doug Cal genomics is
transforming genomics by making
long-range genomic information readily
accessible to all the company enables
researchers and clinicians to solve
complex problems involving de novo
assembly structural variation cancer
research and more by providing a
comprehensive view of the genome their
proprietary proximity ligation and
informatics approaches simplify genomic
discovery by integrating the
highest-quality long-range genomic
information with next-gen sequencing
output for more information please visit
Delta L genome XCOM we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the C button at the bottom left
corner and follow the process to receive
your credits this webcast is designed to
be interactive and we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and any that are not answered live
will be answered by email you can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window and if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speakers first Brandon
Rice Brandon is the head of product
development and strategy at dovetail
genomics and was a founding member of
dovetail he did his graduate work at UC
Santa Cruz in the lab of Ed Greene prior
to his graduate work he worked in the
informatics and software development at
NC gr where he studied metabolic and
hereditary susceptibility to severe
outcomes in sepsis and next Richard
Mitchell Moore PhD
dr. Mitchell Moore is a professor of
genetics in the department's of Plant
Sciences blek Euler and cellular biology
and medical microbiology and immunology
and director of the genome Center at the
University of California Davis he is
passionate about classical and molecular
studies of disease resistance in plants
dr. Mitchell Morris research is focused
on answering questions such as why do
pathogens attack one plant and not
another what are the genetic changes
underlying adaptations in resistance in
plants and virulence and pathogens as
they Co evolve and how can answer to
these questions be used to provide more
durable disease resistance in crops and
improve global food security I will now
turn it over to Brandon and dr. Mitch
dr. Mitchell more for their
presentations thank you Judy so I will
begin by giving all a an overview of who
we are doing what we do and some of our
core technologies as well as some of the
projects that we've worked on so at
dovetail we are genome assemblers we do
everything that is needed to go from a
sample to a full genome assembly
including DNA extraction library
preparation and sequencing all the
computational aspects including the full
de novo assembly and the scaffolding
with various data types we're a service
organization so everything is on-site
nothing nobody has to worry about doing
anything in their own lab we are
particularly good with proximity
ligation technologies of which Chicago
and hi-c r2 and these technologies are
really nice for doing genome assemblies
I'll show you here in a few slides and
we've been at this for a while now
having done over 200 genomes delivered
to our customers and many more on the
way this is a glimpse at the menu that
we have as I mentioned we do everything
that you need to get from a sample to a
genome assembly in particular we are
very good at high molecular weight DNA
extraction and we can make both
conventional Illumina shotgun libraries
and conventional textile libraries
as well as our proprietary proximately
ligation libraries which are Chicago and
dovetail Heights see the aluminum fact
validate our great for de novo assembly
and the Chicago and IC are great for
scaffolding to get up to full
chromosomes we also perform the
computational aspects of things of
course and for the Illumina de novo
assemblies we use a tool called
miraculous from the jgi and for the
tactile assembly as we use the assembler
Falken that is produced by PacBio and
then we have our own in-house pipeline
called high rise that's purpose-built
for taking advantage of the unique
features of proximity ligation data for
scaffolding any type of assembly so as I
mentioned our core technologies are
these practically Legation data types
and those are illustrated here the
principle difference between these are
where you begin and where you end so
Chicago begins with pure high molecular
weight DNA that is first reconstituted
into chromatin which in this cartoon up
top the DNA is the black strand the
chromatin is adding histones which are
the blue circles once you have added the
created the chromatin then you've put
all the pieces in place we will need to
carry out the rest of the protocol for
IC we begin with native in situ
chromatin which is fixed in place in the
nucleus and then after both of those
processes we get to the common panel
which shows a cross-linked chromatin
molecule and so what has been
accomplished in both cases by the
cross-linking is bringing bits of the
DNA that are distant on the sequence
close together spatially and that's the
key to these technologies and how they
enable you to access very long-range
information on conventional platforms
like Illumina sequencers so there once
you have the crosslink molecule then
we're going to go in and we're going to
cut that up with a restriction enzyme
that is going to turn that one original
long molecule in the many short
fragments what the association is
retained between those fragments by the
crosslink backbone once you've gone and
cut it up then we go and we fill in the
ends to make them blunt and prepare them
for ligation and while we're doing that
we also have a marker that will later
use to enrich for the most informative
molecules in the library and that's the
green circle in this cartoon on the next
step there we are going ahead and
ligating performing random ligations
within these chromatin aggregates and
you know the ends will find whatever
ends they may and they'll link up and
form new chimeric molecules in the vast
majority of cases once you've done that
you've effectively created your you're
sequencing molecules you're going to
actually go ahead and sequence so then
you can reverse the cross links get rid
of the proteins and then on the far
right of this panel we're showing now
that we're back down to just pure DNA
although it's been transformed a bit the
markers the green circles indicate the
the remaining markers that we added
earlier on and those are enriched for
chimeric segments and so if you look at
the numbers one and two if you follow
them along through this car - and you
can see that at the very beginning
they're very distant in sequence based
perhaps 100 kilobases apart but after
we've gone through this entire process
we've linked them together into one
short sequence of all segments so then
if you want to begin to get a sense of
the the form of these data we can take
the read page that we get out of these
libraries we can map them to a reference
or human reference for example and then
we can look at the distances spanned by
the read page and that is what's being
plotted here so this is two data sets
one chicago data set which is in green
one hi-c data set which is in purple and
it's the same data in both plots the
only difference between the two is the
x-axis scale so on the x axis we have
the genomic read pair separation and
then on the y axis is the proportion of
read pairs in the library at a given
separation so if you look first at the
left plot I've drawn a couple of lines
on here to help appreciate the scale of
this information so we've got
conventional shotgun data which is on
your hundreds of base pairs and then
there are mate pairs which typically
span from one to ten kilobases long
reads like pack
ont are spanning tens of killed aces or
in the very very best cases hundreds and
then we've got other typical of
scaffolding technologies like optical
maps or others which can span distances
up to about 100 kilobases the live lines
have you appreciate the scales then the
curves are the the real Chicago and
high-speed data and so you can see the
Chicago data has this kind of
characteristic decaying insert
distribution that will go out to the
maximum length of the DNA that we put
into the library preparation typically
that's between 100 and 200 kilobases and
this is a typical library so you can see
that the signal kind of decays and decay
is until eventually it falls into the
noise looks like in this case at about
200 250 kilobases
that is a consequence of the beginning
with the high molecular weight DNA of
the chicago it will distance your
distribution will span as large as your
DNA the high c is different because the
DNA is fixed in place in the nucleus and
so your contacts span the entire range
of possible distances that can be
spanned including up to the full length
of the chromosomes so on the left pot
you can see it's a very similar
distribution for the high-speed data
although it declines much more slowly
and that's because much more the data
stands long longer distances so on the
Left plot we're going out to about five
hundred kilobases whereas on the right
plot ruing out to a hundred mega bases
and I've gone a black line on the right
plot to indicate the maximum extent of
the x-axis from the left plot and you
can see that this Saifee data is really
beautifully spanning well out to that
hundred mega bases before it's dropping
down into the noise and that is ample
signal for scaffolding assemblies and
tuefel chromosomes so now I'd like to
give an example of a project that
incorporates both of these data types to
go from nothing or tissue to begin with
and all the way up to full chromosome
assembly at the end so the project that
I'm showing here is a bird it's Bob
white that we did with Brant Faircloth
at LSU
and we perform this entire projects we
Brandt sent at some tissue we extracted
the DNA and prepared shotgun libraryies
and Chicago libraries and also high C
libraries directly from the tissue and
what's being shown in each of these
plots and we'll see a number of these
I'll take a minute to orient everybody
is the each square or box on these plots
represents a scaffold from the assembly
the data that is being plotted within
those boxes in all cases is PI C read
pairs and it's specifically the density
of pi C read pairs so more intensity on
the color scale and indicates a higher
concentration of high C read pairs
mapping across any given pair of
positions in the genome so pairs that
are close together and these plots will
fall very close to the diagonal and
pairs that are far apart will fall
further and further from the diagonal
ideally what you like to see if you have
a perfect assembly is a nice strong
signal along the diagonal and little
else out too far from them so on the far
left here we have a picture of the
high-speed data as mapped against maps
and plotted against the initials novo
assembly that is generated only from
shotgun data and the scale here is quite
a bit different from the other two it
only goes out to about 80 mega bases and
that's just because the pieces are so
small that you wouldn't be able to see
them otherwise but each of these little
blocks is a little contact or scaffold
that you get out of the shotgun de novo
assembly once you have gone in and
scaffolded using the highrise pipeline
and the chicago data you get to the
middle plot and so here now we're seeing
the full genome scale this is the entire
genome now that's being plotted not just
a teeny mega bases and you can see that
everything is trying to come together
very nicely and so the scaffolds in this
case are ordered from biggest to
smallest and because we're probably the
hi-c data you can see a lot of joins
that will be made eventually but haven't
been made yet by the chicago data
nonetheless these scaffolds are greatly
improved compared to the de novo
assembly finally on the right we have
the
scaffolded assembly after we have
applied the dovetail hi-c data and now
we're seeing beautiful full chromosomes
so despite the fact that there are many
small scaffolds here each of these is in
fact a full chromosome birds and then to
have these many of these micro
chromosomes and that's what you're
seeing here so there are many of them
but each one of these is a full
chromosome and we did this project with
Brandt in right about two and a half
months of which six weeks was sequencing
so we're able to turn around this
beautiful high quality assembly very
rapidly so I'll show a few other
examples because we have applied our
technologies in our pipelines to pretty
much every type of critter imaginable
all of these have gone through a similar
process in some cases the customers made
the de novo assembly isn't given to us
to scaffold and others we made the de
Novo's ourselves but they've all had
Chicago and hi-c applied to them along
the top you can see the progression of
the EM 50s as you apply to different
data types so that interval assembly on
the far left the N 50 after scaffolding
with Chicago in the middle and then the
final n 50 after scaffolding with high C
at the end although that final in 50 is
it gets to be a bit meaningless because
at that point we have full 4 chromosomes
so it really just becomes a measure of
the average size of the chromosomes in
the genome on the Left we've got a
lizard you can see we went from 500
kilobase added Chicago got to 15 mega
bases and then after item high C it got
up to 90 mega bases and I believe this
is something like 19 chromosomes that
were expected and we get 19 nice big
scaffolds in the middle is a fish I know
it's a bit harder to see than the others
and I apologize for that
this one has something like 23 or 24
chromosomes and again nice improvement
from Chicago from a very fragmented
input 24 to a base starting point up to
12 mega bases and then again after I can
hi-c data or back up to full chromosomes
and then finally on the right is
the project that we have been working on
with Richard for for some time and he'll
tell you he may tell you much more about
it this is a lettuce so here we have the
assembly that Richard handed us to begin
with which had about a 500 kilobase in
50 to start after a number of different
Chicago libraries of different sizes we
got up to about six and a half mega
bases and then after adding the hi-c
were again back up to nine super
scaffolds for nine chromosomes so works
really well on pretty much anything you
can imagine we've seen all the
challenges that they are that are out
there in genome assembly we haven't
solved them all yet but we're working on
it
and one challenge in particular that
were we're tackling right now and are
making nice progress on is polyploid so
this is a project that we did with dan
rocks our and his collaborators at jgi
this is a tetraploid grass Miscanthus
and what you can see on the left is one
of our ecology linkage density plots the
same as the other ones that we looked at
where we're replying the hi-c data
against the scaffold and you can see
that same kind of nice big chromosome
level scaffolding with at this scale
good order and orientation so we're
happy with that but because it's a
probably ploy there are additional
challenges that arise so we wanted to
take a closer look and on the right what
we're doing is showing a mummer plot of
the Miscanthus against the sorghum so
these two are about these plants they're
six million years diverged the the
genome duplication event in Miscanthus
is that they occurred about four and a
half million years ago and so when you
compare that our Miscanthus assembly
against this high quality sorghum
reference you see exactly what you'd
expect to see which is two copies of
each sorghum chromosome in Miscanthus
and they appear to have very nice colon
: e arity for the most part of the
sorghum and the one or two major
differences that you can see are real
differences between the two and those
have been validated by these customer
so it looks good compared to the sorghum
we're getting a couple scaffolds for
each of the sorghum chromosomes but you
still want to know if we're properly
separating the homeo logs so these
collaborators also thankfully had some a
genetic map and so we were able to go in
and see how well we were separating the
homologues and I apologize for the poor
labeling here but wanted to be sure that
I was able to get this in so did it in a
hurry and what we're looking at here is
the genetic markers on the x-axis so
each column there is a linkage group and
we're looking at our scaffold or the
scaffold of our assembly along the
y-axis
each box being representing a scaffold
so in the best case what you see here is
a perfect correspondence between one
linkage group and one scaffold if you're
mixing up the homie logs and and you
know putting some of sub genome a along
you're going to see any given scaffold
spreading across multiple linkage groups
but nicely we don't feed out here you
see a very nice separation of the homeo
logs into their respective and separate
scaffolds so we're very very pleased
with this this of course not an entirely
turnkey and automatic process it does
take a bit more manual effort to finish
off assemblies like these but we are
working on automating that further and
are happy at least to have an approach
to - to assembly music so lastly I will
finish out with a note on the nice
complementarity between these two data
types particularly for fragmented inputs
like de novo assemblies that begin from
shotgun data alone it's really nice to
have both the Chicago and the hi-c data
the Chicago for getting nice very
accurate ordering orientation and taking
you from that low contiguity input to an
intermediate scale that's more suitable
for use with the hi-c data and then of
course the hi-c data is really nice for
getting up to full chromosome length
scaffolds and to you know drive home
this point about the importance of doing
this
wise fashion when you're starting with
more fragmented input reporting some
data here so this is real data from one
of our assemblies of the scaffolded with
both Chicago and IC and along the top in
all of these plots we are plotting a
single scaffold and each of the dots
represents a single read pair mapped to
that scaffold and the x-axis position of
the dot is the midpoint of where they
map to the scaffold and then the height
the y-axis position of the dot is the
separation between the two so you can
see there's quite a bit of density close
to the bottom of the plot and then less
and less as you get further away as you
would expect to save some of those inter
distributions that are looking at
earlier so along the top we have the
scaffold in with all of the contexts
within it and what is presumed to be the
correct order and orientation and then
in the bottom plots we've gone ahead and
introduce artificially manually 50
kilobase inversion and then repotted the
data and so we have the chicago data on
the left side and IC data on the right
side and so we're trying to show here is
the very strong signal for detecting
that error that inversion of the content
within the scaffold in the chicago data
that is no doubt present in the hi-c
data but much much harder to see and so
I'm I'm guessing that you probably
spotted it by now at least in the
Chicago data if you can see it in the
hi-c data then give me a call above to
talk to you but if you haven't there it
is right there and so you can see that
there's this increased concentration of
Chicago read pairs that are kind of
further away than you would expect them
to be from the bottom of the plot which
indicates that they are further apart on
the genome than you expect them to be
and that's a very nice signal for
detecting and correcting miss joins or
miss orientations or not making those
types of mistakes in the first place so
with that I'm all set and we'll turn it
back over to Judy
Thank You Brandon for your informative
presentation we will now hear from dr.
Mitchell Moore
great well thank you for joining us I
didn't spend about 30 minutes or so
describing some of the interactions that
we've been having with the dovetail
technology and how we're putting them to
use so no we we live in interesting
times in that we have at our disposal
increasingly very powerful technologies
that are really disrupting our ability
to do clan genetics and use that
knowledge for crop improvement there are
series of the ones that I've listed on
the slide here all the same major driver
for this is DNA sequencing we're getting
credible throughputs particularly from
the Illumina machines we're getting even
longer reads this is leading to
chromosome scale assemblies that are a
foundation for a lot of the work in
terms of doing genetics and manipulating
crop trades we get an even simpler
instruments like the Oxford nanopore and
that's opening up the ability to look at
epigenomics which after this point we've
been some of you ignoring because we
didn't really have a chance to the
technology to be able to analyze it and
then the so that those top
characteristics are really our ability
to characterize variation and then of
course we can actually do something
about it using the genome editing
technologies this is they've been
leading to unprecedented amounts of data
and it is big challenge and therefore
having people that are experienced in
handling very large datasets and getting
the data out of it that we need is
obviously both a need and an opportunity
I'm not going to deal with the bottom
three opportunities there but today
really I want to focus on the
applications of dovetails technology now
the group of plants of my lab has
studied for many years are members of a
composite' family otherwise known as the
Asteraceae they're characterized by
their compound flower the in fact the
compulsory family is probably the most
successful plant flowering plant family
on the planet in terms of numbers of
species and diversity of habitats
as over 1600 General over 20,000 species
and it represents over 10% all
angiosperms and one of the attractive
things about this group of plants too is
that their colonizers of disturbed
habitat so potentially they are a great
source of alleles for looking at adverse
environments they're over 200 species
domesticated edible medicinal also owns
a lot of weedy species and many of the
ornamentals do over a council and things
like that of course feral composite'
however the family doesn't have any of
the rules of big six crops so it's a bit
of an orphan family in terms of it
deploying genomic resources and I've
been part of a consortium of labs that
are trying to rectify that situation but
some of the more famous crop species
that we have a leaded sunflower
safflower artichoke than the medicinals
like Artemisia echinacea and the famous
weeds things like silence downline all
of it all your thistles they're also
members of composite' but the most of my
labs efforts well you can see from this
slide I like to joke with sort of
tightly focused on about 8 different
projects part of my lab is focused
around on lettuce and then we have a
compulsory Genome Project within the
compulsive team my life has been
studying chicory on dive and artichoke
we're also very interested in molecular
basis of disease resistance and its
pathogens protecting the Dani mildews so
I've got a number of projects with
dovetail the ones that I'm primarily the
PI on are circled in red and ones that
are collaborating with more dotted lines
and the we've also because we're a
technology driven lab we've got
sidetracked into a sequencing doing
genomics on pistachio that I'll talk
about later and we have a number of
other projects so it's a much my lab
over the years to be focused on lettuce
there
so a good deployed it's got a genome
size about the same size of humans we've
now sequence set as I'll describe in a
moment
it's an ancient Archy of poly plied it's
probably domesticated as a weed it's now
over 2 billion dollars per annum farm
gate value in the u.s. 80% of that
production is in California so we're
about four percent of the agricultural
economy in California ok so when you're
online you may want to keep going back
to this like this really lays out this
talk and it follows how we've been
putting the genome assembly and refining
it over the years but just to walk you
through it on the left-hand side about
five six years ago we collaborated with
the vgi and they did a really great job
of putting together the primary assembly
it was all alumina based and that gave
us version 3 we then genetically
validated the assembly cleaned it up a
bit and in both cases we did annotation
that gave us v5 now then we took the
genetics and however many scaffolds that
we could map that generated v6 which was
everything we could map into sudha
molecules and then we took v5 and did
two lanes of Chicago I must feel that 18
months ago now that led to v7 and again
we checked it out genetically and
constructed student molecules that gave
us the eight at the same time we did
some more Chicago I'll go into great
detail in a moment but that gave us from
v5 the input I gave it seven point two
and again we did genetics and
constructive student molecules on that
that gave us V eight point two and then
we hi-c came along and so we generated V
7.3 and with a modified version
high-rise v 7 point 4 so I'm now going
to walk you through these different
stages so we can get a better look at
what how things went on so I said the
first input or first genome assembly was
straight alumina based we made a whole
bunch of libraries rather BG I did good
mate pair libraries all the way up to 40
kV and so we had about 110 ex-royal
sequence that was polished dropped down
and when you're doing it in limited
sequencing on the very important points
is to work with really high quality
sequence don't try and incorporate bad
sequence if you need more reads sequence
some more and throw out the bad reads
they ran the soap de novo we can add in
genetic data gene space data we have
transcriptome data and that gave us our
annotation so what we ended up with is
an N 50 of 476 KB which for the time
it's pretty good for a 2.7 gbg gnome and
we got 93% assembled close to 40,000
gene models we could well when you get
assemblies back it's very difficult to
know how good they are you know how does
the assembly reflect what's actually on
the chromosome however we were able to
look at the scaffolds pull out
polymorphic markers and use our genetics
and what that showed was that many of
our if we got three good markers were
able to show that actually the majority
of the assembly was genetically
validated only about 3% 0.3% and after
three or more links groups and therefore
probably miss assembly so that allowed
us to align 60% of the assembly 5
strokes enter the total into chromosomal
linkage groups which the time 5 6 years
ago we were fairly pleased about
oh forget the numbers this is really
what the loaves genome looks like a lot
of retrotransposons and the genes are
buried in this matter repeats so this
really puts a challenge on doing genome
assembly with Illumina reads so then we
heard about the dovetails Chicago
libraries at a pag meeting and I must
have been several back now and we
collaborated with them they ran the made
Chicago libraries ran high-rise I say
this gave us v7 and you can see the big
jump here this is two lanes of Chicago
and we jumped from an M 50 of 476 KB
after 1.8 mega bases we could then
genetically I'd test them and only 25%
that's less 25 scaffolds less than 1% or
chimeric and the super scaffolds tended
to map into nine chromosomal linkage
groups so we had then about 3000 soup
scaffolds coming 2.3 gigs
97% of the assembly and because they
were large we could then orientate the
super scaffolds we could locate a
combination point within the soup
scaffold and that was allowed us to
considerably increase the resolution of
the suta molecules so this is what the
genome will look like this is the vs mv7
genome assembly that's just been
published in Nature communications and
they say we we were fairly happy with
that it allowed us to look at the
archaea polyploid whole genome
duplication and triplication
which is shown in the middle so every
part of the or many parts of the lettuce
genome we're actually in triplicate you
can see by the different colored lines
joining three parts of this genome now
let's say there were some things that
we put together genetically into the
sewer molecules cameras that the
dovetail information said there were
chimeras
it wasn't very many it was only 74
scaffolds out of 21,000 but then when we
went back in and actually had a look at
the scaffold per se we could actually
see what the problem was that the
Chicago data had actually revealed the
miss joins which was because we had high
quality at one side was the break point
that they accurately predicted you can
see quite why we had relatively few
snips and they weren't high quality so
it was very useful to keep see soaring
back and forth between genetics and the
Chicago data the other thing you want to
do to validate it was we could take the
largest asuka scaffold with nv7 and
which was 12 mega bases and we could
then look at the component scaffolds
that have gone into making that up and
then we could look at rills commons
inbred lines and select those that were
recombinant over cross this interval and
then we can see actually that the
component scaffolds had in fact been
assembled in precisely the correct order
because the de cáncer double crossovers
but basically it was very very
unambiguous that the high-rise had done
a very good job of assembling the
component scaffolds interviews large
soup scaffold okay so we're very
interested in disease resistance genes
disease resistance genes in plants tend
to be clustered in these large clusters
and lettuce is no exception
for example our major is what we call
major resistance gene cluster 2 we've
got eight specificities
to downy mildew resistance genes it's
got resists to root aphids when you go
in and look at the sequence assembly
it's got large numbers of these
canonical of NBS and our our genes or
the NLRA
it's got receptor like Karnazes and a
bunch of other genes depicted up here if
you go to the lab the lower half of this
slide you can see that the gene models
predicted there and it's a mixture of
both the so called Chanel type and the
tal side and we have these genetic bins
so the genetic resolution here and what
you see though is that the genes are
within sometimes a genetic thin and we
don't know the order or the orientation
of the scaffolds within the genetic bed
so here we've filtered the section at
the top you've got the component
scaffolds in in dark blue from soap de
novo and then lighter blue you've got
the genetic bins and you can see that
we've got multiple scaffolds within a
genetic bin with a super scaffold then
you've got much better resolution and
therefore we're able to order on the
local scale the component scaffolds that
were coming from the circular and over
assembling so the resolution of the
genetic and physical maps are now
similar which is very informative but it
was still you know we wanted to get
better and so we persuaded dovetail to
try and get ultra-high DNA which they
did from seeds and this then allowed as
we say as the brand was saying it is
very much driven by the size of the
input DNA and the initial Chicago
libraries for 100 Kb
I gave us about two lanes to give us
that 72x coverage and I've just sort of
summarize that for you already with a v2
assembly we then made two additional
libraries with genomic fragments as
shown here as being well over 200 KB
that gave us an assembly coverage of at
least 130 X and then this allowed us to
raise the end 50 up to 6.5 mega bases
which is contained in
400 scaffolds so the using the larger
DNA and greater coverage gives a good
bit better resolution then the hi-c came
along we've actually made three sets of
hi-c libraries from dry seeds from young
expanded leaves and from flower beds
because I wasn't sure I felt the
chromatin packaging the in vivo
packaging might actually be denser in
the dry seeds and therefore it might be
more informative for long-range the
long-range contact information however I
needn't of worried because the the only
hi-c data we've used to date on with
high rise has come from the young
expanded leaves and what we ended up was
was basically nine chromosomal super
scaffolds and which we were so we we did
feed it a very good input assembly so
the infant assembly with 6.5 mega bases
you add in the hi-c data and basically
we've got chromosome scale assemblies as
shown here so the m50 as I say is 295
mega bases which is pretty meaningless
the N 90s 90 percent of genome is having
93 to 99 percent of the assembly are in
these chromosomal super scaffolds and I
like to joke that the the tomato folks
will never have an N 50 as big as mine
because their chromosomes are smaller
than mine 50 and if you think about it
there are several Arab adopts of genomes
end to end in one of these super
scaffolds gives you a feeling for the
how impressive the scale these
assemblies is and when we validate that
genetically in the right hand the dot
plot there you can see that we get very
good or diagonal lines for each of the
chromosomes
there's a little bit of noise that's
shown here going across but we've got
the nine live stupas caporals are
basically collinear with the nine
chromosome link
oops we had another six smaller super
scaffolds containing quite a few
scaffolds you can actually see them just
a trace of the top of the left hand
figure or the right hand side there +13
smaller ones so let's say we have a
background of Miss assignments
now then dovetail use this information
to polish the way that high rise is
causing the contact frequencies and
you'll have to talk to them exactly what
the tweaks were but this allowed us then
to really clean it up the 19th smaller
super scaffolds were now correctly
placed in the super chromosome of super
scaffolds and you can see that the
background chromosomal misalignments has
been greatly reduced and this is now
placed 99.3% of the assembly into
chromosomal super scaffolds the other
thing we wanted to do was because we had
a number of project starting out was how
important was the size of the input
assembly and because we'd done it
progressively and fed a very good
assembly in with a high rise data we
wondered well that was overkill and so
they ran the v5 input that is the input
with a 1050 of 476 KB plus only the hi-c
data and what you can see it's fairly
good you get a nice chromosomal thing
but the it isn't contiguous so we had
the N 50 105 mega bases and the chrome
many of the chromosomes were split into
two to five pieces so the total of 34
super scaffolds really made it made up
the whole genome so comparison then
you've got the plot on the bottom left
hand side you can see that with the
yellow line there it's virtually all of
the assembly is in these very large
molecules the input assemblies shown in
that blue line and you so that the two
two plots there on the right left-hand
side giving the comparison of the effect
of the size of the imprint assembly
emphasized will appoint that Brandon
made earlier that the Chicago and
Heisley libraries are complementary and
then we can look at what that does to
the to the resistance gene cluster that
I just talked about the bottom half of
this slide I've already shown you when
the top half is really taking in the
green blocks to the input scaffolds from
v5 and now they're just one contiguous
block all the way along as part of
chromosome 2 so really this is reduced
almost all ambiguities in in the genome
assembly and this is actually showing is
V 7.3 one of the unlocated scaffolds we
had before in 7.3 is actually part of
this cluster and V 7.4 added this in so
here's a summary table that gives you
the stats of walking across the in 50
size you can see we've gone from 476 all
the way up to chromosome scale you've
got the numbers here it's here for your
perusal I don't want to walk through it
in the interest of time but I will make
the point that the from the v5 to v7
there was no new really no new sequence
added what the whole process was
improved ordering an orientation of the
component scaffold so where are we going
now we've got about as far as we can I
believe with our current assembly so
what we're now doing is adding more
sequence back in this is involving
PacBio we've now sequence 32 smart cells
is about 15 X we've got some very big
libraries in there we're putting that in
so we're using the fact bio for
scaffolding and gap-filling we're also
using 10x chromium libraries which are
going to give us fragments for the 52 or
to do a long fragrance of 50 100 KB
region
we'll put that in will then use the
dovetail scaffolding with both Chicago
libraries and the hi-c information we'll
still have some gap filling to do we'll
do that from the back by sequences will
genetically validate what's going on
right then reality and so the v9 will be
a completely reworked genome but as you
can imagine is taking some time to do
that so we're we're using this type of
information well let it's like any good
plant gets all sorts of diseases we have
most of these diseases you see on this
panel you wouldn't want to see in your
lettuce salad
we've got mapping populations for all of
this and we're really trying to pursue a
candid gene approach to clone many of
these genes and facilitate their
integration to generate multi deck multi
disease resistant lines so here we've
got a heat map of the different linkage
groups we've got all of these phenotypes
that are mapped and as you can see
asterisks provider cloned the genes
involved or we're targeting the cloning
really having a accurate chromosome
scale genome assembly is foundational
for these efforts we've been doing that
based cloning now for quite a few years
but having a chromosome scale assembly
is really accelerating the process and
drilling down can to genes with much
faster with and with much more
confidence so here's just an example of
mapping the phenotypes to the major
cluster resistance gene stem here
they say this is allowing us to drill
down and get candidate genes so so step
back then I think we're really at the
point we can have a relatively efficient
resistance gene discovery pipeline as
shown the top right hand side here and
we're using the same types of
technologies on the pathogen side I
haven't had time to talk about it today
but and when
as far along but we're using dovetails
technology on the premiere pathogen as
well we haven't on the assembly Zepa
hopefully we will in the next couple of
weeks and then we can put these two
datasets together and we can then have a
deployment strategy that will hopefully
result in much more durable disease
resistance at the moment the pathogen
responds for the Selective pressuring
imposed by resistance genes so they're
quite quickly if the resistance genes
are released individually they get
overcome so what we need to do is to be
able to pyramid resistance genes and
then have deployment of the of the
resistance gene stack so that we are
maximizing the evolutionary hurdle
placed on the pathogen population fruit
become veralyn and these ideas are not
new Roy Johnson back in the nineteen
eighty-four wrote a very good review
it was published now whose fight ecology
it's worth going back and reading that
but they really didn't have the
technology to implement it and now I
believe we do and give a shameless plug
for review that we wrote a couple years
ago this really takes Roy's ideas and
puts it in the context of the
opportunities and technologies that we
have today jumping a little bit just to
illustrate some very recent data on
pistachio none of you would claim that
in fact pistachio is in any shape or
form a model plant species it's got a
genome size it's nice it's only 600 mega
bases
however it's deiicious out breeding it's
highly heterozygous and really very
little genomics data is known about it
it's actually an ancient domesticate
from the Persian area it's a very recent
California crop it's now about a billion
dollars in increasing it's an also an
interesting crop because it's grafted if
you look at the tree the right-hand tree
only in the top right-hand photograph
you can see a ring halfway up the trunk
there that's the graphs point so you've
got one species on the top which is
pistachio vera and actually the bottom
the rootstock is an f1 hybrid seedling
between two other species so it's a very
interesting set of three species a crop
is really three species looking at that
to work out what's going on and Sally
Kafka in Turkey is devoted much of his
life to this and he's been developing
genomic resources we're collaborating
with him to work on pistachio vera and
the data that we just got back earlier
this week
here is a chromosome basically Assembly
of pistachio vera this material that
based on an input assembly of 78 KB and
dovetail ran both Chicago libraries and
hi-c
and we're able to get a 23 megabytes and
50 base gives nine with nine scaffolds
the longest scaffold 31 mega bases we've
got 17 major super scaffolds now the
stache show has 15 chromosomes his also
- this has got the sex chromosome so
we're very very close to having super
scaffolds to go across every chromosome
and we've got 98% now there's only 400
hundred 14 mega bases of the genome
assembly in here and it should be about
4 that with the size of the input
assembly now the other the female here
we've had a much better input assembly
savvy calf coasters generate worked on
this much more and the n50 there is one
point 5 mega bases all it was necessary
was to have a high C libraries made on
this and now you can see we've got much
better now we've got 16 major supe
scaffolds with 99.9 percent of the 400
and 600 600 14 megabytes assembly that's
close to the whole genome then in
chromosomal suit scaffolds I'm not quite
sure where the which ones will have to
be joined it might be some exterior the
sex chromosomes so
you know what we're going to do next
there we need to refine genetically
validate these but he's looking very
good we're doing chromosome scale
Assemblies of the two rootstock parents
this is going to lead to high resolution
QTL mapping in both in all species for
agricultural important traits this Zoo
is going to allow us to have very
informative molecular markers for
selection in this in this relatively
long-lived crop species so I feel it's a
very good example of rapid development
of genomic resources for a little
studied non model species a couple of
years ago we didn't even know the genome
size so to wrap it up then I'd like to
acknowledge a lot of people in my lab
who has done much of the work
particularly Sebastian very stream row
has really been leading the needle the
latticework William Palmer and Yelina
Joker out have been doing much and
pistachio work and then Dean Laval and
Marie Jose and Alex also been doing much
of the background work on the lens
genome and the phenotyping I already say
enough for the collaboration there's
been a great interactions we've had the
whole series of people it does tale
listed some of the names here and I'm
sure that many others in the background
the FS are I this has been a great
collaboration working on on lettuce and
then the less internationalized genome
consortium this is done in collaboration
with a group in bargaining and we're
working on where wild species lettuce
and we're going to use dovetail on that
as well like to acknowledge the funding
comes from a consortium of companies as
well as the lens grows and the pistachio
Research Board the growers have been
remarkably supportive over many years
for developing genomic and apply or
developing and applying genomic resource
into classical plant breeding as well as
the federal agencies and with that I
like finish thank you
thank you for the informative
presentations before we begin the
question and answer session I want to
advise that a series of poll questions
will appear on your screen you may
select your answers then close the poll
questions by clicking on the X in the
right corner we also like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question is for dr.
Mitchell Moore do you feel comfortable
now scaffolding only with Chicago high C
data and forgoing the genetic map that's
a good question
I actually think Gen X is great genetics
doesn't lie
and it's a very good independent metric
as to how good your assembly is so if
you have genetics I would definitely use
that information there will be miss
joins and so I say yes you you need to
use genetics if you can however it's not
possible in all species so you need some
other metric something we're doing in
other species where we don't have
genetics is to look for synteny in
related species so if you're doing
dovetail in parallel species you can
basically cross-reference both and see
whether you get the same synthetic chain
order dr. mitchell more this next one is
for you too did you notice any
differences in the biological signal
between the three different tissue types
you used for hi-c
okay that's still a work in progress as
I said we thought the hi-c data from
seeds might be more informative than the
ones and leaves but it certainly wasn't
necessary we just done the first sort of
visual comparison between the three data
sets and the predominant signal is for
the contact frequency reflecting
proximity down the chromosome we're not
seeing very strong signals of intercom
as oh Mille associations within the
interphase nuclei we
of course was the original reason that
hi-c with developed way back but as I
said it's still a work in progress and
yeah we can see sometimes these X's in
the hi-c data whether that's reflecting
the structure maybe the telomeres are
coming together as well in the nucleus
but as I say that he's still a work in
progress
Thank You Brendon this next one's for
you are there any major differences
between dovetails high-speed data and
that produced by others yeah in a
principle no kind of signal within the
data is the same from my library sisters
or mothers we do have a streamlined
library preparation protocols it only
takes a couple of days as compared to
you know some of the earliest published
protocols are on the order of closer to
a week so we streamlined that quite a
bit
we're one of that really folks to adopt
I see for tissue as opposed to only for
cell culture so we have worked with a
extensive array of different tissue
types and it works for pretty much
anything of course there always limits
but that's on the adds a front as far as
the data goes you know it's fairly
similar although talking to Richard a
bit earlier it sounded like the the hi-c
data that we produced and gave them was
a bit cleaner in terms of the
signal-to-noise content okay this next
one I believe is for you dr. Mitchell
more great work on pistachio how are you
planning to deal with the heterozygosity
of this species and would you be able to
construct super scaffold representing
different haplotypes this is very much a
learning curve for us we actually it's
the same issue with premiere the the
Danny mildew both of them have very high
levels of heterozygosity it's also one
of the reasons that we're pulling in the
10x assemblies because they're the
initial output
ostentatiously anyway keeps the two
haplotypes separately and what we're
considering doing is submitting to the
dovetail analysis both the uncollapse
and with ones with the hopefully the
happy tight separate and then the
collapsed one and looking of what we get
back so I think the jury's out on that
one you know it's a similar type of
issue is when you're considering dealing
with polyploid I think it'll be very
much on a species by species okay to a
case-by-case basis because it'll be
driven by the amount of diversity that
you see between the informative low copy
sequences randomness next one is for you
can assembly is generated by any means
be scaffold with loose Chicago and or
high C and so what qualities do you look
for in put assemblies yeah it's a great
question the answer is yes assemblies
made by any means can be scaffolded with
our data types and pipelines as far as
you know what quality is do we look for
the you know more contiguous the input
is to begin with typically the better
the final result will be so we do like
that initial assessment as contiguous as
it can be as far as kind of standard
recipes go when folks are using shotgun
data for the de novo assemblies we
always recommend getting both Chicago
and hi-c data to cover kind of the
intermediate information scale with
Chicago and the chromosome scale with
high C that's really important for those
those types of input assemblies in
particular excuse me when you have a
PacBio assembly in auto cases you can go
straight to high C and get a really nice
high-quality scaffolding but we tend to
take does on a case-by-case basis but we
are always happy and willing to consult
with folks they're not sure about the
current assembly we have means to assess
the quality of those and make some
guesses around how the process is likely
to go so
folks are wondering or not sure you're
always welcome to reach out to us
Brandon next one's for you how long does
it typically take to go from tissue to
delivered assembly that will depend on
the nature of the project some projects
we do our scaffolding only some are
everything from the de novo assembly
through scaffolding to the gap sewing
and all the rest in the fastest cases
typically it's on the order of about six
weeks or so we can do entire projects
including the de novo and scaffolding
bits in the order of a few months three
months or so and that was the case with
the bobwhite that I showed which was
done in two and a half months so
certainly much quicker than the human
genome I would like to once again to
thank Brandon and dr. Mitchell more for
their presentations again all unanswered
questions will be replied to by email do
you have any final comments I'm good all
set thank you very much cheating oh
great okay I'd also like to thank our
sponsor dovetail genomics for making
today's educational webcast possible
please stay tuned for details on their
next leverets webinar on coffee
presented by dr. Susan Strickler of
Cornell University this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through November 31st 2017
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay and we invite you
to afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time
goodbye